Liam Ezra view in all these you know
action sequences were you know young
strong people but it was in Expendables
2 that you got quite badly hurt
yeah yeah we were doing the same with
jean-claude van Damme and lovely guy at
one point the scene he has a moment
where he supposedly kicks this knife
into my chest and we did a bunch of
takes and on this one particular take he
gave me a full van Damme kick to the
chest
Wow and I dropped to my knees everyone
called Chiron yeah yeah like proper
proper hit me in the chest and sort of
dropped to my knees and I had my hands
too hard tied behind my back as well and
the first ad camos like you okay am i
yep yep no I'm good I'm not gonna show
any pain to Van Damme and I stood up and
then he takes his glasses off he turns
me I see it's okay it's a controlled
kick
there was nothing control about it you
kicked me in the chest
just kick spot man down he fell on it
you know if you're gonna get kicked by
someone that's a pretty good person I
encountered him once you we were on the
show on this show but I've encountered
him between between that the controlled
kick line and this I worked with him for
four days or something that the other
thing he said to me he came up to me at
one point and he took his glasses off
again these glasses through the hall
saying he came over and took his glasses
off and looked at me you have a good
face a similar thing on the Hunger Games
before I'm sure yeah yes it's probably
worse she often brought before a tyke
would turn to me and asked me if I liked
having sex with kangaroos or anything
along those lines you know I really know
what's gonna come out of her mouth your
answer was absolutely
a lady called Beatrix on a Twitter
tweeted sam neill to say hey are you
aware of this unit out see you've got
the tissue under the elbow which you
have here because but let me just give
the audience context it's a lot that